welcome to every damn day the sketch
comedy group goat-face has their
self-titled special premiering on Comedy
Central on Tuesday 11 27 at 10:00 p.m.
welcome back to Baba knows best the only
game show where real Brown dads compete
for cold hard cash we're down to our
final three dads let's meet them up
first an aerospace engineer from Seattle
Washington give it up for Mohammed now
Mohammed I hear one of your hobbies is
reading the newspaper I love loose paper
okay our next Baba is from Fremont
California he's a mechanical engineer
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Akbar Farah I hear you were recently
kicked out of a Costco for trying too
many samples I go in and they said no
sir you cannot keep eating dirt don't be
a chip with salsa I said goddamnit I be
I will need as much sunshine cheap as I
need to do our last Baba's from
Baltimore Maryland he's a structural
engineer ladies and gentlemen it's
Nasser Nasser I hear that you like to
mow your lawn in your speedos what do
you mean on the forum
you had one of the activities you like
to do is write mowing the lawn or
Morland in your speedo inside a speedo
what am I going to do wear my underwear
so we sent our very own Chris cotton out
to Los Angeles to talk to him check it
out
[Music]
time to play get a no go face I want to
act on some surface level questions to
see if you're really our friends great
decided okay this question is about
assets what is the first thing that ISIF
will buy if you won the latter I know
the answer to this but I want to see
what you'd say he might be playing I
feel also doesn't have any glaring
problems or like tells of what he waste
his money on you know what I mean maybe
a nice car one sure that'll come later
but he's brown so he's practical so
he'll probably invest and he'll probably
put it in the house aasif would buy
yogurt franchise
straight what's up that isn't aggressive
the fact that you know that that's very
specific yes you know he would give me a
subway right yeah yeah a subway oh girl
amber yo girl in quickly edged out
subway because I learned that yo girl
and you only need to wait and the
customer this is why yo girl and beat
subway the customer makes the food
themselves so you're not doing anything
I'm not doing anything and there's no
riffraff families and children huh I'm
just raking it in all day and you're
doing nothing who wants to pay sandwich
artists nobody wants to pay sandwich
artist man but everybody take me a walk
sir there's a yogurt artist exactly
honestly if you need an investor I got
ever had a more practical Groupon here 2
Chainz is like I'm gonna get a
Yogurtland I'm going to suze orman route
to change 2 Chainz was an accountant
actually before he became a rapper so
I'd be willing to buy the CPA what was
his name titty boy was titty boy CPA no
I'm in a 2 Chainz video for like a split
second video the one with the cars it's
like a racing it's like a racing thing
like he plays someone who like won a
race and I'm interviewing him I have a
microphone and he you're literally not
helping I was gonna try to describe it
more I go it premiered on worldstar oh
my god have you say one more thing about
this video I don't need this piece I
definitely need to be alright next
question it's about feed alright here we
go alright
what adjectives best describes Fahim
family just know my mom watches this so
don't crush our feelings right now I
would say excuse I would say cautiously
judgmental cautiously I would say I
would give
answer in the form of like like a little
theater piece so it'd be like this so in
the in the scene I want you to say dad I
won an Oscar dad
I want an Oscar do better
can we rock on this case that's so funny
funny if he's like he wanted a Teen
Choice Award yeah yeah like it goes
Oscar then Teen Choice Award because
it's multi-purpose right I'm gonna go
with aasif yeah
what is Aristotle's biggest pet peeve I
could see them pulling it is everything
I for me I think it's uh at least what I
see is a pet peeve is anything he
perceives as someone trying to take
advantage of him whether it be you know
the price at a store parking Oh mother
I'm his mother for the nonce
yeah yeah he's I'm gonna say parking
tickets even even if he's totally in the
wrong because I'm totally unique in this
town that parking tickets are my bad if
I get a parking ticket I'm like you got
I lost Israel you won this I know I
don't feel like the world is against me
I fight every ticket I win them
sometimes wouldn't lose parking or
traffic ticket traffic tickets I say
about 90% of them I win and what is your
what is your technique if you can tell I
need this you sorry tickets forget it
they will they will not budge yeah my my
tactic for fighting traffic tickets the
law do you hate the most
Oh out of my biggest pet peeve is when
people don't know enough about me
you both got it wrong they both got it
wrong hey so we just learned a lot about
a goat face and don't forget gold face
has a special coming out this fall on
Comedy Central okay
yeah people what they want
[Music]